honor I was going to say he does have a
Cleveland connection that's right I wish
I wish this was the the first in-person
uh Speech and that you guys flew me out
in the uh Cas jet that I've heard so
much yeah right
Sophia's not operating yeah they're
trying to look for people to use Sophia
now so okay there you go yeah think big
so Brian is the uh distinguished
professor of physics at the University
of California in San Diego and
um uh the whole you know the whole story
behind the earth a lot of some of the
story behind the whole [ __ ] thing
um in fact
um thought he was going to be in running
for a Nobel Prize but he didn't get the
Nobel Prize but he he did what the
result was was a really interesting book
okay and it's called losing the Nobel
Prize and this was my summer read this
year when I went to Montana on my
two-week fishing trip and I enjoyed
every minute of it it is it's a
fascinating book I was gonna try to
write some stuff down about it and then
when I looked at some of the reviews I I
couldn't pass up Brian Green's comment
where he said Brian keating's riveting
new book tells the inside story of the
search for Cosmic Origins emphasizing
the influence of Nobel dreams and laying
bare the question of whether the lure of
grand prizes is ultimately a good thing
for science
and he does a wonderful job of it so I I
really really recommend this highly okay
it was it's a it's a good read 300 some
pages
um and um it's a lot of fun you know a
lot of inside baseball stuff about the
Nobel Prize and and what have you he
also has a podcast that's uh that's
quite interesting so uh that I'd suggest
you check that out online
so you didn't come here to listen to me
talk but you'll listen to Listen to
Brian talk so with that I'm going to
turn it over to Brian if you could
welcome
all right
thank you guys thank you Gary's plural
and it's great to be back virtually in
Cleveland where my uh really my career
began and I began courtesy of uh one of
the planets you guys just mentioned
which was Jupiter and we'll get into
that and I was fortunate enough to end
up at Case Western at 1989 first day of
classes was my uh first day on campus
but it had such an enormous reputation
from professional astronomers and and
from um uh being in the news for things
shortly before my matriculation in 1987
a the Supernova and the magellanic cloud
over there was discovered by a case
astronomer as you guys probably know and
uh Peter pesh who was a grand old and
wonderful individual who really kind of
inspired my academic Journey he was my
freshman advisor and so I have fun fond
memories of Cleveland I was back in 2018
for a book signing and a speech at the
synagogue that's on campus that was
super fun
and uh today it's great to be here to
talk about uh things related to the
Nobel Prize it is the Nobel Prize week
after all uh so it's like uh Christmas
for nerds and I just want to ask if you
guys can see my slide uh with me saying
pointing up the cosmic Hall of Fame can
you guys see that
I can't hear anybody saying anything so
it's dangerous to assume anything
um Can someone unmute and let me know if
you can see it we don't we don't see it
yet you don't see it uh well I'm sure oh
I see what's happening here so you think
with three years of Zoom almost uh that
uh a professor would be good enough at
uh at reviewing Zoom that he or she
could actually perform this adequate now
can you see it there we go all right and
you should see the next slide now which
talks about my group here in San Diego
yep great so yes I am Brian Keating and
this is a great treat to be here uh back
in Cleveland at least virtually Hope to
come visit you before your 200th
anniversary uh comes up and uh this uh
is really a treat I mean you guys do
such phenomenal work and Cleveland's
such a phenomenal City I really kind of
regret a that I wasn't a member of the
cas as a as a young scientist but B that
I'm not there in person as I said that
we'll have to wait until next time for
now I'm in San Diego where I have a
large research Group which I share with
another uh wonderful young Professor cam
Arnold who's in the back
for some reason he's 10 years younger
than me but has a lot less hair than me
I don't know why uh but uh but
nevertheless we have a an amazingly
competent and Incredibly diverse and and
just enthusiastic group of young men and
women from all over the planet literally
every continent on Earth has been
represented by people in my group and
I'm just so excited about that we study
the universe and all its Glory at
microwave and infrared wavelengths and
uh there's a web website there but I'm
going to give you homework because I am
a professor I cannot resist uh giving
you some homework here so the first
thing is if you're watching on a
computer screen you can take out your
your iPhone your Android phone if you're
a heathen
um or Windows Phone anyone got a Windows
Phone Palm Pilot anybody get a palm plot
so take out your phone I can see you all
out there and uh you can scan this with
your camera app and it'll open up a
website and if you're watching this on
your phone you can actually go to your
web browser and type in Brian
keating.com list and what I've been
doing is giving away uh free samples of
the villain of my book uh losing the
Nobel Prize the villain of the book
spoiler alert a I don't win the Nobel
Prize in this book in fact nobody in
this book wins a Nobel Prize
um but B the spoiler the villain of this
book is space dust which also goes by
the name of a meteorites and I have uh
little samples of these meteorites which
are samples of failed planets in our
solar system uh that are representative
of the type of signal that we actually
did detect
we thought instead that we had detected
the the aftershocks of the explosive Big
Bang origin so-called inflationary
universe but instead we were undone by
this very very humble substance called
Cosmic dust or as I call it space
Schmutz that's the technical name for it
uh so if you join my mailing list uh a
very high chance of winning a very own
signed copy of a meteorite uh from the
deep innards of our solar system so make
sure you do that you could do that by
snapping that picture or by merely
typing in that address briancating.com
list anyway that's all sorts of goodies
I send out two emails a month and uh
they're pretty fun to write and
hopefully fun to read there's about ten
thousand people that get them every week
um so uh for some reason it is not
letting me use my cursor to do it and
the last piece of homework for now is to
take out your phone or your
um uh you know the computer and type in
to YouTube Dr Brian that's my YouTube
channel and I love it YouTube is online
oh the computer in the back I have a
computer assistant computer be quiet
uh so if you type in this into YouTube
you will get a a request to join my
YouTube channel and there I put out two
to three videos a week and these are
either explainer videos about
interesting topics in cosmology particle
physics from an experimentalist point of
view there's a lot of you heard about
Brian Green from Gary and he has a
friend and future upcoming guest on the
podcast
he blurbed my book so graciously but
he's a theorist and uh nothing against
theorists but uh we need
experimentalists and we need to kind of
champion what we experimentalists and my
colleagues do around the world and
particle physics Laboratories and dark
matter detection experiments and and
cosmology experiments so that's what I
endeavored to do on my YouTube channel
so you can take a picture again it'll
take you to YouTube sign up subscribe to
the YouTube channel and there you will
get either explainers or interviews with
uh so far I've interviewed 14 Nobel
Prize winners uh including uh including
some that won just last year and so
you'll uh you'll really benefit from
their knowledge that maybe not so much
from my knowledge but not only do I try
to get their knowledge what they've done
but also their wisdom and their Humanity
as well as their uh scientific and or
technical accomplishments so I've got
three new interviews coming up with uh
the winner of the Nobel Prize last year
in economics the winner of the Nobel
Peace Prize for global warming in 2006
and also the winner of the Nobel Prize
in 1997 in physics for Bose Einstein
condensate so these are really fun
interviews to do I hope you'll join okay
this just shows you how you can do it if
you're kind of slow and you're using
that Trio or that hand Palm Pilot from
way back when you just go over click
subscribe and you're all set okay
so I mentioned dust I mentioned space
dust and the interesting thing that I
never thought I'd write a book I never
thought we'd really need me your humble
uh correspondent to write a book about
the early Universe simply because there
was so much great knowledge that had
already come from these great intellects
like Brian green or John 11 or many many
other people Lawrence Krauss who used
was the department chair when I was at
Case Western way back when and so who
needs me but I realized again those are
all theoreticians and it would be good
to have an experimentalist point of view
for the people that actually build the
instruments the telescopes the detectors
Etc like my colleagues do and to do that
I felt like I only wanted to tell a
story if I was the only person on earth
that could tell the story and that's
when it came to me to write this book
back in 2018
which uh you know did receive a lot of
great awards no Nobel Prize for
literature sad to say so I'm still
Nobelist but that's okay I won father of
the year two years running which is kind
of sad because my oldest is like 11
years old but but anyway uh we we have
to make do with what we have and I
always got angry at these at these dust
jackets you know whenever you get a book
from the library or you buy them
hopefully on Amazon so my kids can go to
Case Western someday uh the covers fall
off they're getting dirty and they get
all messed up and what's the point of
these dust I mean how much dust is
really raining down on people's you know
bookshelves on a daily very little so I
thought they were Superfluous
unnecessary boring and a waste of time
until I found out a couple things about
dust jackets one is that if you have an
ancient book like I'll be showing you
from the man who introduced me to Peter
pesh and other people and that is Jay
pasikoff
um he told me when I had the copy in my
hands as you'll see in the moment of
Galileo's cedarius nuncie that if that
book didn't have its cover it would be
worth not half a million dollars as his
copy is worth but something like you
know maybe fifty thousand dollars still
a lot of money but nowhere near the
value and I'm not saying that so you
guys all scoop out many copies of my
books but nevertheless uh that is one of
the most valuable things because people
judge books by their covers and without
the dust jacket you really don't have
much the second thing is that there
isn't a lot of importance to dust in our
universe and it's really overlooked by
many of my colleagues so I mentioned
Galileo a second ago this is his own
sketch of his little telescope which is
probably you know about the size of some
people's telescopes that are just
joining and learning about the Cleveland
Astronomical Society I know my first
telescope uh was about this size too and
it's really uh just like you know a
pirate would use here's here's my little
demonstration telescope I keep here but
with this telescope even from downtown
Cleveland Ohio you can see all the
wonders of space that Galileo himself
saw floating over the Tuscan Hillside
back in 1610 and here's an example uh on
the upper on the upper left are those
depictions hand sketches in the cedarius
nuncias which is uh Latin for the
sidereal or Starry Messenger not to be
confused with you know the grass Tyson's
book that came out last week and Neil's
coming back on my podcast next week
hopefully for a second appearance about
his book called The Starry Messenger so
you can steal books titles uh I never
knew that when I was I was hoping nobody
else had my book titles but it doesn't
matter you can steal their titles but
you see in January 1610 Galileo was
looking through this tiny little
telescope just like you can and he saw
all these wondrous sites little stars
going around Jupiter as he later
realized that there must be moons in
orbit satellites which he named after
his benefactors kind of like you know
someone naming something after the
National Science Foundation that they
discover we don't do that anymore we
name it after ourselves or
um and now they're known as the Galilean
Moon so he actually didn't have to be so
uh you know arrogant as he had he had a
very healthy ego which which I'm coming
to realize is is not too uncommon even
among my Nobel Laureate uh kind of
guests on the podcast but he also saw
the creators of of the Moon and he saw
the ears as he called them of of Saturn
that or later turned out to be
discovered by you know Cassini and
others as rings and orbit around
um around the planet and I found out
depressingly that the observations that
proved that the rings of Saturn don't
orbit as a solid disc those are made uh
in Pittsburgh I mean if you can believe
such a thing Pittsburgh it doesn't have
to be Pittsburgh couldn't be Cleveland
anyway it was discovered at uh
University of Pittsburgh or Pitt anyway
he wrote this book it got him great Fame
instant Fame in fact he never left Italy
what would later be called Italy and uh
and yet his Fame spread to every
continent uh known uh to uh to exist
except for Antarctica which hadn't been
discovered back then but more on that
later he published a lot you know
publisher perished it applies to
professors then as now and these are
just some of his books but you see on
the lower right is a book called the
dialogue or dialogue
and you see in the very beginning in the
upper left uh was one of his first books
it's called the compass and it's not
like a magnetic compass it's a it's a
slide roll like a military like a
protractor basically and you see that he
writes down about these uh objects but
there's um it's a military device which
it is and this is in 1600 I believe that
one is 1602 and then the next books then
you see in the next book uh it's the
sudirious nuncias and then the next book
after that that was a letter to the
Grand Duchess of Tuscany and they're
underneath his name you see Academy
academic Yo lenteo which meant that he
had been elected by virtue of his
discoveries into what was then kind of
the Nobel Society of that of that time
it's called The Academy of the links the
links being this animal with big eyes
that's very perspicacious
but um so then all the rest of his books
he he always writes down his name you
know it'll be like someone writing a a
paper that won the Nobel Prize and keeps
saying that he won the Nobel Prize uh
but finally he gets to the dialogue in
the lower right
and if you look at the first
um the the cedarius nuncias which was
the first evidence for the copernican
universe that is written in Latin and
that was allowed he had been cautioned
before that time to not teach the
copernican theory but he was allowed to
do research in it teaching meant
speaking in the vernacular of the people
well the people didn't speak Latin then
as now and uh and so it was okay for him
and and fully uh acceptable for him to
publish many many papers and books about
this except uh he was forbidden to teach
about it but he sort of seems to have
forgotten about it or thought that his
Fame would make that uh uh obviate the
need to publish in in Latin and so by
the last two books of his life he
published as an Italian and that's
really what led to his undoing the
dialogue means the dialogue in Italian
not in Latin uh you see it uh on the
lower right that's the book that made
the classic defense as you all know for
the copernican model and it's entitled
The the discourse of the discussion the
dialogue on two World Systems one being
copernican one being columnic or
biblical on the left
um that's what he was forbidden to do
and here I am with Jay pasikov at
Williams College looking at his copy of
the Severus nuncias is quite
breathtaking to hold a book that's worth
uh more than you know my house or
whatever uh that's it's pretty it's
pretty fantastic and he's very gracious
to show that
um and you see it there and it got him
into a little bit of trouble
as we know although I hope to disabuse
uh those of you who might be under the
impression that he was tortured or
really that he was imprisoned I'll do
that in just a second but if you look at
this object here which you all recognize
as the plei 80s the Seven Sisters or if
you have a certain make and model of
Japanese car it's called Subaru here's
his sketch of that from the Severus
nuncius
shows uh these Seven Sisters actually
there's only six you can see and he was
sort of called by Edward tufty the the
father of data science because or at
least of data visualization because in
this image are two different types of
stars they're the open stars that look
like stars of David maybe that he
sketched and those are stars you can see
with your naked eye and then there are
the stars that you can only see with a
telescope and he thought all of the uh
image of the Pleiades was uh was
completely resolvable and caused by
individual Stars he just knew his
telescope wasn't powerful enough to
resolve them so he said the fathering
thing he said what we observed is the
nature or matter of the Milky Way itself
with the head of the Spyglass may be
observed so well that all the disputes
of whether it was made of individual
stars or not are destroyed and we are
liberated from the stupid philosophers
wordy arguments so they love to you know
kind of tweak philosophers even as
physicists back then
now of course we know he's wrong because
anyone who's ever imaged the Pleiades or
even a small telescope knows that
there's nebulosity and that what Galileo
is claiming is that you can actually
resolve that nebulosity the nature of
the Milky Way was as cloudiness this
milkiness so he was wrong it wasn't
actually fully resolved there's no
telescope powerful enough to resolve the
bluish smudges there into individual
stars because they're not made of
individual Stars they're made of silicon
and carbon and here's a Hubble Space
Telescope on the lower left so he
believed that he had proven it to be
true because he called it visible
certainty in the previous quote but it's
actually a reflection nebula and even
some scientists believe there's actually
diamonds in the pure carbon so it's like
uh Twinkle Twinkle Little Star was right
all along
now what was the first thing he decided
to do with this Discovery Well he tried
to sell it uh to to his patrons and
other patrons in the city-state of
Venice so he went from Tuscany and went
over to Venice
and uh he tried to persuade them to buy
it they didn't buy it really in the
quantity that he had hoped but they
allowed him to publish it and they also
made him fully tenured professor of of
natural philosophy and Mathematics and
they doubled his startup so it's pretty
cool for a professor's point of view
we'd love to have our startup doubled he
thought he'd be famous and go on a book
tour and sign copies like uh like Kim
Kardashian is doing here but instead he
was uh bold and Brazen and published a
few years later the dialogue as I said
again he keeps touting he's a member of
the link Society it's kind of cute uh
that even this great intellect was so
insecure with his uh accolades and so
forth he had to put it on every book
um and he presented it and gave it to
the Medici in 1632. the only problem was
he was forbidden to do that as you know
uh he was forbidden to teach and I was
teaching in Italian so he got into a
little bit of trouble with the supremist
of Supreme Courts at the time the
Vatican the pope Pope Urban the eighth
who had been his tutor to 2T under his
tutelage shall we say is Protege uh so
Galileo tutored him as a young boy and
um thought he could Curry special favors
maybe they forgot about it you know but
the Catholic Church doesn't forget very
easily and in fact they've never fully
pardoned Galileo they've said that he
was right John Paul uh II in 1987 or so
did say that 1992 did say that Galileo
was right but they never pardoned him
and said you know may I culpa Maximus so
here's a depiction of him in the Holy
office there's a guy with a sword next
to him over there so here's where his
prison quote unquote was and is and uh
and it's quite spectacular place in fact
we have a a couple of of conferences
held there in his Villa it's a stately
20-bedroom uh mansion with olive trees
you see me in front of the olive trees
in the on the lower right
you could just about see the Duomo uh
the Pinnacle of Renaissance uh
architecture and really the beginning of
the artistic
um you know kind of Central Central
place that the Renaissance would would
have and that being in Florence so it's
an amazing Villa to to you know I'm sure
Bernie Madoff would have loved to have
been in this prison so
um now I had a great honor just recently
to be the first person to ever make an
audiobook in the first you know three
people among the first three people to
make an audiobook uh with a small uh
cohort of people including Nobel Prize
winner Frank wilcheck uh director of
CERN uh Fabiola gianati and uh Jim Gates
who's the founder of super String Theory
so we all read from this book and it
takes place over four days and it's
really delightful you can get a copy of
it on my website and no one's ever done
it before I thought that was a shame
because it's one of the best books I've
ever written not just the best science
books ever written it's one of the best
books and that's what Albert Einstein
calls it in his forward that Frank will
check winner of the 2004 Nobel Prize
reads that Einstein said this is
unmatched before or since and so it's
quite amazing
so you can find that on my website under
my books at briankeen.com so there are
Jim Gates and myself recording this uh
and you can get uh all the figures of it
actually made an nft of some of the
figures just to have fun with it
hopefully I won't land in jail uh but
Galileo had all these different mottos
and and I love to you know kind of go
through mottos and I wonder you guys
will tell me sometime if the Cs has a
motto but Galileo had all these mottos
uh including the Bible shows us the way
to go to heaven not the way the heavens
go I do not feel obliged to believe the
same God who endowed us with sense
reason and intellect had intended us for
us forego them of their use that was one
of his mottos so he's kind of like you
know being Brazen and there's him
looking a lot less
um you know kind of Meek in front of the
person who would become the Pope in this
particular depiction now again he was
wrong he made many blunders just like
Einstein you know I always joke that
Einstein made at least seven blunders uh
including you know what he repeatedly
called his biggest blunder about dark
energy
and that uh one of Galileo's blunders
and and I always say you know it's too
bad because Einstein could have had a
good career you know if he didn't make
those blunders but uh Galileo had the
same kind of greatness and the same
kinds of blunders so in the dialogue
the most convincing piece of evidence
according to Galileo was the depiction
that the tides on the Earth's surface
are caused by the combined rotation of
the earth and the revolution of the
earth that those two motions just as
water in a cup of water or in here if I
were to spin this around and rotate it
around maybe you could get some kind of
behavior that's what he called the
origin of the Earth's oceans tides
totally wrong Earth's tides are caused
by his friend the Moon on Hulu's surface
he discovered the first craters and
depiction that it was actually not
unlike mountains and volcanoes and and
Landscapes and planes like the Earth
so it shows you that great minds can be
uh capable of great discoveries create
insights and great wisdom
and also be completely wrong in other
cases so I like to you know discuss that
in the context of the Nobel Prize in the
book where I met you know make the
distinction between knowledge and wisdom
and part of the mission of my podcast is
to have so many of these Nobel Prize
winners on and uh and see if by
accumulating their knowledge that they
along the way of accumulated wisdom so I
don't only ask them to describe the
physics of a Boze Einstein condensate or
of the accelerated expansion of the
universe with with Brian Schmidt and
Adam Reese but I indeed asked them to
get into aspects of their humanity and
what drives them and how do they compete
and collaborate with other scientists
how do they know when they're wrong
that's one of my favorite questions to
ask you know what have you changed your
mind about in science or outside of
Science and and it's surprising there
Candor and intimacy that you get to know
somebody when you ask them questions not
only about what they do scientifically
so his third model
allegedly muttered under his breath
Galileo was and yet it moves so he was
right the Earth does move but the proof
that he had was wrong so he was actually
right but for the wrong reasons and it's
it's kind of curious why he put so much
stock in this and uh but but he is of
course a hero to all of us uh scientists
and really Einstein calls him the father
of the scientific method not only the
first physicist of modern
um you know kind of incarnation uh the
creator of the first theory of
relativity
and he did all this with a small
telescope that only allowed him to see
stars in the Milky Way he never saw
outside of the the realm of the of our
own Galaxy which is which is fine and
understandable uh for such a small
telescope and if you fast forward about
a hundred years Herschel and Caroline
and William uh observed the uh observe
the sky and They too had blunders or
mistakes caused by the same types of
distortions and biases that Galileo was
misled by in the case of the Pleiades
namely that there are nebulae and there
is dust in our galaxy and they were
totally unaware of that and so they
caused them when they tried to depict
where is the earth in the center or not
of our galaxy Galileo showed we are not
the center of the solar system but maybe
our egos would not be bruised so much if
we were the center of the Galaxy so the
herschel's 100 years later were kind of
misled by similar types of Illusions so
these are figures from my book
my first book losing the Nobel Prize
with a great graphic artist Shaffer grub
and he's showing you that the effect of
the presence of dust when you don't
account for dust in the cosmos either in
our solar system in our galaxy or in the
cosmos
you are subject to many different types
of Illusions one is that dust tends to
make objects of given brightness appear
dimmer and then since astronomers equate
or tend to associate brightness with
distance or inverse distance you have
closer means brighter
um dust will reduce your ability to
perceive and measure accurately distance
if you don't take into account so the
left window has no dust on it the right
window has dust on it you could tell
which one you might think is farther
away even though it's the same Spotlight
or street light dust also because of its
length and the wavelength of visible
light causes light to become both redder
and polarized and that's both going to
be important in our study of the cosmic
microwave background and the so-called
bicep 2 affair
so uh you are all familiar with this
even if you go out to Lake Erie and you
look out on the lake uh close to Sunset
I don't know if you can see it exactly
like this this is taken in the Pacific
Ocean but anyway uh you notice that the
that the sun looks redder more orange
than it does at High Noon when you look
at it straight above it looks looks
yellowish green above now the sun
doesn't change it's color we know that
it's because of the excess opacity in
the path Optical path length has more
dust in it as you Traverse as the sun
goes at higher and higher larger and
larger Zenith angle and that's familiar
we correct for that as astronomers today
but back then they really didn't and not
only did the atmosphere cause scattering
effects this one's a little too blurry
to read but it causes uh microwave light
to become more and more
red more and more dim and more and more
polarized and this explains the origin
of the illusion that caused Herschel the
herschel's to misappropriate where the
Galaxy had the Earth located within it
and actually we know it's actually
located about you know two-thirds of the
way out um on one of the Galaxy spiral
arms and that's just like if you're
inside of a cloud on a jet going
um home to Cleveland the uh it looks
like you're kind of inside of a ping
pong ball a spherical ping pong ball and
so it looks like it's centered upon you
even though the cloud could have this
weird you know classic Cloud shape as
depicted on the left same thing happens
in our galaxy not caused by water
molecules but by dust and dust also
causing light to become more red and it
causes the light to become more
polarized so here's an accurate
depiction of the Galaxy
so if we fast forward from the
herschel's to the early 1900s there was
a great debate
is the uh Milky Way galaxy now the
center of the universe so Galileo
disabused us the Earth is not the center
of our solar system the herschel's
eventually once we corrected for their
dust Distortion we knew we weren't the
center of the Milky Way Maybe please God
can we be the center of the universe and
all we had to go on is the
two-dimensional images that we see and
even have a picture of one behind me
over there in my office here
uh and the question was whether these
swirls that look very similar I mean the
Orion Nebula we know is a nebula the
whirlpool Galaxy now we know it's a
Galaxy 1923 we didn't so there's a great
debate and it was resolved by Edwin
Hubble famous Edwin Hubble who really
measured uh the presence of a type of
star called a cepheid variable in our
nearest neighbor Galaxy the Andromeda
galaxy and by doing so he could measure
the distance to it using Henrietta
Levitt's law and measure a distance of
something like uh seven to ten times the
diameter of the Milky Way galaxy now we
know it's about
um approximately uh 2.3 million light
years away
closer to three million light years away
and uh and so it couldn't be possible
that the Andromeda nebula which is what
they called it was actually in our
galaxy it's way too far away so this was
a discovery that there are other
galaxies conclusively and then later
um when he was measuring these galaxies
to make his famous Hubble diagram he
overestimated the expansion rate by a
factor of seven because in part he
didn't take into account the reddening
of light due to dust and so red light
exposes more poorly on photographic
plates than does white light and so the
reddening of the dust and the Andromeda
galaxy was uh was detrimental to his
estimation
um and furthermore the dust also
diminishes that that light as well so
because of that he overestimated how
fast the universe is expanding and since
the Hubble constant
uh its inverse is the age of the
universe he got an age of the universe
that was seven times too small
so it turned out that he had estimated
that the age of the universe is only
about 2 billion years old and now we
know it's about 14 billion years old and
so that was embarrassing because back
then they knew of of radioactive decay
and they knew of Ages of certain
compounds in the earth
um by the late 1920s that uh in early
1930s that meant that Hubble was saying
the universe is all is younger than the
objects within it so it'll be like you
know you being younger than your mother
or something like that it didn't make
any sense and so it caused people to not
believe the Big Bang Paradigm for a long
time again dust is impacting how we
perceive our place in the universe
so that was the Hubble Deep Field now we
fast forward another 50 years or so
Penzeys and Wilson winless prize there's
me holding my book in front of the
Homedale antenna uh in New Jersey and
they discovered a hiss glowing in all
directions that would later turn out to
be the cosmic macri background
once we remove the the average
temperature signal in the cosmic ray
background 2.726 degrees Kelvin you're
left with these faint fluctuations that
are called the CMB anisotropy and one of
my guests John Mather who is now the uh
Chief scientist on the James Webb Space
Telescope he's been on the podcast two
or three times now
um he talked about this discovery and
what it meant and how close they were to
not making this discovery uh back in uh
when he won the uh Nobel Prize in 2006
that was for work he did in 1991 and
1992 with a huge team of scientists on
Kobe
so the question is how do we explain
those fluctuations and this brings us to
what I actually do
there are fluctuations once you remove
the mean 2.7 Kelvin signal that are at
the level about 100 micro Kelvin so a
few parts per 10 000 really really quite
smooth in fact smoother than any
billiard ball or or bowling ball that
you guys might ball with there in
Cleveland I remember going to some Lanes
out there myself many times uh but uh
the the explanation of a finely kind of
sort of almost tuned Universe needs to
be explained where do those fluctuations
come from that's the signs I try to do
so what we're really endeavoring is to
explain the the imprints the fossil
relics of the cosmos when it was an age
of about uh of about a hundred or maybe
uh 10 trillion seconds which sounds
pretty old but it really equates about
380 000 years I guess it is pretty old
but it's not like trillions of years old
and we're trying to infer from that what
did the universe look like when it was a
trillionth of a trillionth of a
trillionth of a second old or so and I
always equate that to
the universe being
um like a human being so on the lower
right is what's called a blastocyst
which I always joke is what you look
like a thousand seconds after your own
parents had a big bang of a certain kind
um hopefully there's no little kids
watching but um uh but nevertheless then
asking imagine you looked at that blast
assist you see that picture you say what
is this person going to look like
um oh I know what it's going to look
like it's going to look like Midwestern
or native Oprah Winfrey let's just say
and she's about two billion seconds old
which is about 60 years old and uh it
would be ludicrous to try to do that and
yeah that's what we're trying to do
we're trying to basically use a version
of what's on the left upper left to
infer uh what the universe was like and
the lower left and no one who wasn't
crazy would try to do that on the upper
right to the lower right but we're
trying to do that and what we're really
attempting to do is go beyond the
Pleiades go beyond the Hubble Deep Field
go back to that modeled image of the CMP
and try to Divine from it what the
universe looked like trillions of SEC
trillions of trillions of trillions of
seconds after the initial origin of time
itself perhaps in the Big Bang
to do so requires the observation of the
less the least Familiar of Lights three
properties so light has a intensity a
brightness has a color but also it has a
type of polarization and polarization is
familiar to us uh we have polarized
sunglasses so here's one of them and I
could turn it left and right and it'll
get darker my image will get slightly
darker slightly brighter depending on
the polarization I can take two
polarizers and I can cross them and I
can use them to block out light so
there's two of them and I can rotate
them and I'll become brighter and dimmer
there so we make use of the cosmic
polarization in order to reveal the
leftover fragments of the Big Bang in
this case they're called gravitational
weights they're not exactly the
gravitational waves that ligo discovered
and won the Nobel Prize for two of my
past guests Ray Weiss and Barry barish
but they have some things in common they
last forever they travel at the speed of
light and they are the result of massive
objects in violent Motion in some
context so in this context the universe
is the most massive thing you could
imagine coming to existence in a
trillionth of a trillionth of a second
is the most violent expansion and
acceleration one could ever Envision and
so there could be Relic waves of gravity
from that same event that's what we're
looking for and if true it'll produce a
type of polarization called B mode
polarization that's what we search for
to do that we had to build a telescope
and that telescope had to be cooled down
to 454 degrees below zero fahrenheit and
it's exactly what Galileo had built
himself which is a refracting telescope
except instead of his eyes we use
superconducting detectors instead of the
retina and instead of glass lenses that
Galileo ground himself we use pieces of
very very high Purity polyethylene
basically the same as milk jugs are made
of and we make a one foot diameter which
is a pretty big refracting telescope if
it were made of glass that would be
quite expensive but um but these milk
jug type materials are quite cheap but
the detectors are incredibly expensive
and the instrument itself is quite
massive and has to be taken some are
very special so it's about three meters
tall it has its own Twitter account so
you can follow it there and we had to
take it to the very bottom of the world
Antarctica
uh this image came out in the magazine
nature when they reviewed my book in
2018 I think it's kind of cute shows
cosmologists searching in the heavens
for a Nobel Prize which is somewhat of
what my book argues we took it to the
South Pole which is the dead center of
Antarctica it's the axis and the
southern hemisphere that the Earth
rotates upon and so there it is from
below so to speak
to get there uh in the past it was only
discovered and reached in 1911 and it
was reached by two teams within three
weeks of one another and that three-week
difference made all the difference of
life and death literally for the lower
team the British team well you see they
took a different technological approach
to getting there the the Norwegians use
sled dogs and then the sled dogs had a
had a virtue in that they were also much
better than people in terms of you know
just running and not asking questions
and not worrying about their you know
their loved ones at home but they could
also be eaten once they got to the South
Pole and that's what they did the
Norwegians the British with their stiff
upper lips could not make do with eating
dogs so they became the beast of burden
on the lower depiction there and that
meant that they consumed a lot more food
and fuel had more rest stops and
three-week difference that they got
their second meant the difference
between life and death they all died
uh it's still a very dangerous place to
get to as this image shows from my first
visit to the South Pole so um and don't
anyone let you you know try to get
tricked into catching a penguin they're
quite dangerous and they're not even
nice to people I mean they're they're
quite violent animals so um don't let
their cute disposition and depiction
fool you
here I am uh taking my Instagram shot
down there this is the first time I
think I went down there I've been there
twice for a total of about a month it's
an amazing place but it's it's pretty
boring there uh the people make it
durable and and durable but they uh the
landscape is just like shown there uh
flat white no mountains no animals
nothing but a couple of scientific
experiments and there's ours and you see
in the upper right are these little
sticks in the sky and those are
depictions of what the polarization that
I told you about would look like if the
universe was suffused by gravitational
waves where those waves were caused by
inflation oh by the way if inflation is
true then something called the
Multiverse is true I don't have time to
get into that but suffice it to say that
there would be an infinite potentially
infinite number of copies of every
single one of us if the Multiverse
concept is actually true again I don't
have time to get into that but when we
made this announcement in 2014 on St
Patrick's Day it was covered around the
world we claim we discovered and
detected that pattern the very pattern
which would indicate that inflation took
place
and so there's a press conference at
Harvard
there were Nobel laureates in the
audience and there was a viral video
from Stanford University one of the two
kind of founding theoretical fathers of
inflation Andre Linde so hopefully an
upcoming guest on the podcast uh he
promises me uh and there he is and the
Stanford you know kind of PR team made
this video
uh two weeks before the announcement
that's pretty glitzy and it shows my
colleague Charlene quo
used to Professor Andre Linde who is the
founding father of invitation so
inflation is the theory about the pain
of big bang it explains why we have all
this stuff in the universe so today I'm
going to tell him our experiment bicep 2
plays itself Paul has found the Smoking
Gun evidence of inflation he has no idea
that I'm coming
so I have a success yes
as clear as they are upon you
so he's telling him that we've detected
inflationary gravitational waves minus
and they have champagne and they talk
about it we're on CNN
and we were on every newspaper around
the world
um sure the Cleveland Plain Dealer
covered us as well
but the most important newspaper of all
of course the San Diego Union Tribune
they covered on the front page New York
Times some other Small Town Newspaper on
the right there
I like the image at the bottom The
Economist because this kind of sounds
like some guy was just like watching and
then oh man I saw the beginning of the
universe how cool is that uh of course
you're not really sure you've made it
until the onion debates you abates about
you and they did have a story about us
including whether or not it's possible
theoretically to give somebody their
heart forever because of b-mode
polarization and there's Michio Kaku
past guest on my podcast Aretha Franklin
pasca no I didn't have her heifer I
would love to have had her Diana Ross
Smokey Robinson uh so they can be in
this panel uh fictitious panel uh
shortly after our announcement and yet
and yeah we were always nervous and
worrying and wondering did we actually
detect what we thought we detect because
it was so big that we thought it was
basically too good to be true and again
spoiler alert the book is called losing
the Nobel Prize
um and so you see these uh housekeepers
and they're saying sure it's beautiful
but I can't help but think about all
that Interstellar dust out there
so what does that mean well just as
there are meteorites that you can win if
you subscribe to my newsletter at Brian
keating.com list so I urge you all to do
that uh it looks like about 12 of you
have done that so far so please keep
those coming uh you can also find
micrometeorites and even smaller
fragments of the uh failed planets or
exploded supernovae that produces this
material that I showed you later in the
earlier rather that you can get if you
subscribe to the mailing list uh here's
a little chunk of it that I keep by my
little uh video recording set up here
and so smaller and smaller elements of
this material is made of metal you can
hear it when I shake it and that metal
is highly magnetic and the Milky Way has
magnetic fields in it so actually if
there's dust in the universe in the
Milky Way galaxy it can get aligned and
reproduce that exact same pattern
that we were seeking and searching to
find and would therefore ascribe to be
the imprint of the inflationary universe
and that's actually what we ended up
measuring so we we didn't have this
clean pristine picturesque view back to
the early universe is depicted here by
Schaefer grub instead the universe is
kind of smoggy filled with soot uh it's
a lot like Pittsburgh isn't it I mean
it's it's so it's so ugly no I love
Pittsburgh but but anyway we can't be
too nice to those guys
um and so but dust is not only bad it
destroyed my Nobel dreams uh at least
for now but it also produces the whole
planet that we're on as Carl Sagan said
and I had his Widow andrewian on the
podcast and his daughter Sasha sagin on
the podcast so uh it's really been a
treat to have this podcast since uh
covid started it really kept me
um from going into depths of despair
but Sagan said every Satan sinner lived
on this pale blue dot it's just a moat
of dust suspended on a Sunbeam and
that's really lucky for us because we
have star dust flowing in our veins as
the song goes we are Stardust uh the
iron in our blood came from a supernova
explosion just like this meteorite did
so we should always be uh kind of of
mixed Minds about dust it destroys Nobel
prizes but it creates planets and people
uh as well so Nobel dreams Blown Away in
the dust as all these jokes made at our
expense uh as I described in the book
but it um I was sat on a uh a journey of
Discovery not long after so after we
retracted our claim that we had
discovered the imprimatur of inflation I
um I you know I hadn't really thought of
writing a book at that point but soon
after I got this letter in my mailbox at
UCSD and it was asking me to nominate
the winners of the Nobel Prize for the
next year
that's kind of embarrassing it'd be like
if I you know Gary asked me to to give a
talk here I said you know can you
introduce me to the Pittsburgh
Astronomical Society that'll be really
cool it was kind of humiliating that I
was asked to nominate the winners of
maybe a prize that perhaps I could have
won in 2016. so here's the letter don't
share it with anybody please you see at
the upper right it's strictly
confidentials don't tell anybody but
I've underlined a couple of sentences
here it says work done long ago may be
selected for the award only on the
supposition that significance has until
recently not been fully appreciated
then slightly below that
says candidates and plural that's
interesting so I when I was asked to do
this in 2016 2015 I was kind of curious
uh what exactly did Alfred Nobel want so
I went as a scholar should to the
original Source material and here's
Alfred nobel's will this is written a
year before his death uh in November
1895 and I speak fluent Swedish and
Norwegian as I know you all do so you
can read no I can't even read his
handwriting but what he says in the uh
in the translation is that the whole of
my estate all of it should be given out
as prizes every year to those people who
in the previous year shall have
conferred the greatest benefit to
mankind a portion has followed one part
to the person in the singular who shall
have made the most important Discovery
invention in physics so now I go back
and I look back here and says work done
long ago maybe so well that's not that's
not last year that's not preceding year
it doesn't say one person that says
candidates plural this week three people
one in fact a single person by himself
has not won it in him unfortunately
there's been only four women upon it in
121 years
but um incredibly they say plural but
Alfred said the single person and
nowhere in this letter does it say that
anything to do with conferring the
greatest benefit on mankind so what goes
on here imagine if you wrote a will and
the lawyers and the kids I don't care
what good old mom or dad wanted we're
going to do whatever we want and we're
going to do it for our own purposes and
that's what I've come to realize that's
what the Nobel Prize has done
now a lot of people say Keating you've
got sour grapes jealous you know and I
say look you know if you want to see if
I'm being honest about the criticism of
the Nobel Prize just get them to offer
it to me and if I don't reject it then
I'm a hypocrite so we'll see what we can
do now I want to give it just a quick
quiz uh I won't belabor this there are
three Nobel worthy discoveries but only
one of them won the Nobel Prize and I
want you to think
um you know out there you can raise your
hand if you think number one the RNA
molecule won the Nobel Prize so raise
your hand i'm watching there on Twitter
okay anybody think that anybody think
that the perock table so Mendel was
alive he could have won the Nobel Prize
uh there's even an element element uh
102 I believe uh is called nobelium it's
named after Alfred Nobel
so did that win the Nobel Prize raise
your other hand if you didn't okay the
lighthouse anyone think the lighthouse
won the Nobel Prize anybody not like
raising their hand unzoom so just raise
your hand if you don't like to raise a
couple of you so of course the
lighthouse
um invented in the early 1900s good
stuff to Len uh came on it for for
physics okay for automatic gas
regulators in conjunction with gas
accumulators for Illuminating
lighthouses and buoys in 1912 by the way
this was only seven years after Einstein
came up with the theory of relativity
and Einstein didn't win by this time uh
and their reasons for that had to do
with anti-Semitism and other things but
there's been a lot of controversies here
three laureates that have had great
controversy people have never rescinded
the Nobel Prize people nominated Trump
for the Nobel Prize there was a sex
abuse Scandal uh in the Nobel Prize for
literature so it was canceled two years
ago
um uh just incredible that it has so
much Prestige there's never been a Nobel
Prize retracted even for outright
racists and uh like this gentleman
William Shockley
I said that uh it's basically saying
that African Americans uh should be
effectively uh impeded from uh
reproducing a form of eugenics uh this
guy then became the donor to in San
Diego we used to have this place called
the sperm Nobel Prize sperm bank which
has been shut down I don't know if
anyone ever made a withdrawal from that
particular bank I hope not uh but this
guy was a complete racist and uh there's
been you know homophobes and sexists and
all sorts of things no one's ever had
their Nobel Prize retracted unlike the
Oscars or Emmys or gets retracted you
know people
um commit Grievous sins
so um another bad problem with the Nobel
Prize is that it unfairly kind of is
excluded women and uh so I think that
may have started from the beginning
because he gave twice as much money to
his nephews as to his nieces so he had
no wife no children Alfred didn't have
uh either one of those so he gave some
of his money to his nieces and nephews
but the nieces only got half as much as
the boys so maybe that could have
something to do with it so when I wrote
my book
uh there were only two women who would
ever want it Marie Curie in 1903 60
years later you see San Diego's own
Maria Gephart Mayer she won it in 1963
and our physics department here is named
after her
um since my book was published two more
women have won it and I'll get to that
in just a second because I'm obviously
responsible for no I have nothing to do
with that but here's the headlines in
the San Diego newspaper when she Maria
Gabbert Mayer won the Nobel Prize it
says San Diego mother wins Nobel Prize
that's pretty uh astonishing that that's
how they uh they they talked to her and
they talked and other I met her son
before he passed away uh six years ago
and he told me that they said even worse
stuff like she was just a housewife
uh she was far from that she was a
genius uh uncovering the mysteries of
the nucleus
but then you think things got better in
2018 uh one of my colleagues wives or
widows actually of my colleague Andrew
Lang
um she won the Nobel Prize in chemistry
and here was the headline NASA had the
headline Caltech mom wins Nobel Prize
sun is JPL Mars flight technician but it
doesn't mention the woman Francis Arnold
who won the chemistry prize so anyway as
I said two women have won it since then
we've doubled the number of women thanks
to my book again that's just joking
people watching out wherever you're
watching uh Donna Strickland and Andrea
Getz who's a UC La Professor up the road
from where we are in San Diego
so that's some progress but you know
since then no women have won it again so
we'll see uh they'd have to give it only
to women for the next 70 years for them
to equal the number of men who have won
it I don't think that's going to happen
so a man who didn't win the Peace Prize
but surely deserved it Mahatma Gandhi
give some advice so actually
um Hitler was nominated for Nobel prizes
but Gandhi never won
um so he said that we need to be humble
or humbler than the Dust seeking after
truth envisioning that dust could crush
us and I thought that's kind of cool so
what do we do now that we know that dust
interferes with the cosmic signals we
seek well we have to do something to get
rid of that dust and to do that we've
constructed the Simon's Observatory
which is in on track to be the world's
highest and uh and largest Cosmic
Observatory of its kind when it achieves
first light or first microwave in two
years from now in 2024.
uh it's made up of many many uh
collaborators from every single
continent here's what we look like back
in 2019 when we were last together and
just this summer we had another meeting
here in San Diego I have even more
collaborators uh it's a huge
collaboration I'm grateful to be the pi
of it and running this 100 million
dollar project thanks to donations by
the Simons Foundation New York City the
heising Simons foundation in um in La
the Bay Area and our member institutions
so what is it that's a giant vacuum
cleaner stuck out in space no it does
people ask me how can you get rid of
dust without a giant vacuum cleaner
actually you can get rid of any Cosmic
signal you want as long as you dedicate
an experiment to measuring it it's
called a systematic effect and so we
have dedicated frequencies to look for
dust remember I said it makes the light
redder and redder so we have channels
that can't see the cosmic signals but
can only see the dust and that's what
we're building into the Simon's
Observatory that we did not have in the
bicep 2 experiment
we have a massive six meter diameter
telescope it actually has two six meter
diameter towels very different than any
telescope I'm sure you guys have not
only in size but in configuration it has
these particular properties that are
almost optimal for measuring
polarization
it sits in a building 15 meters high and
on my YouTube channel today I posted a
video linked to observations of its
first motions about it as a building in
Germany where it's being constructed
it'll be shipped to Chile later this
year
now the detectors are shown there on the
upper right that sits in a camera that's
um that's two and a half meters in
diameter so it's it's bigger than the
Hubble Space Telescope uh primary mirror
that's just the detector chamber that
has to be cooled down to 0.1 degree
Kelvin so almost absolute zero
and in addition to that we have three
smaller telescopes depicted here uh one
of which is in my lab at UC San Diego
and we're going to measure those these
are kind of analogs of the bicep 2
experiment except about seven to ten
times more powerful more detectors
colder Optics colder detectors and three
times as many telescopes as shown on the
right
and they look at dust and they look at
the cosmic signals and from the two we
can distinguish between the polarization
caused by dust and the polarization
caused by the cosmic inflationary bmos
we have to go to a very cold site a very
high site this is in the Atacama Desert
it's one of if not the highest
construction project on Earth at 17 000
feet you have to wear oxygen masks there
you see it there it's under construction
this picture I have some um more recent
pictures here uh where this is actually
two years old now I should update this
we're pouring the foundation we have to
do everything ourselves we have to bring
concrete up there where everyone's
wearing oxygen we have generators we
have safety equipment we have to have
our own water toilets we have to have
our own roads concrete diesel fuel
Diesel power generators everything is is
done by us it's incredible we don't get
any support from like the National
Science Foundation to do any of this
it's all based on the private
contributions so it's going to be loud
for a second but then I'll fast forward
so here's pouring concrete in a
snowstorm at 17 200 feet where the
pressure is half of that in Cleveland or
San Diego
so it's another you have to wear these
tanks of oxygen on your back or you'll
die
or get severe brain damage or chronic
pulmonary Disorder so a whole bunch of
fun things could happen to you if you
don't wear oxygen here's a photons I
view from a drone we have uh flying over
those three small telescopes of this
about a year ago it's also not far from
an active Minefield between Bolivia and
Argentina and Chile they never get along
um and you can visit us at
simonsobservatory.org here's our logo
and I have a lot of videos about that in
my channel and Dr Brian Keating on
YouTube and I describe the origin story
of that experiment and the bicep 2
experiment and a little bit of a cosmic
Memoir is what this book is about
there's only three chapters helpfully
color coded in Gray I don't know if you
can see that there there's three
chapters about the Nobel Prize the rest
is about the search and the desire to
understand how our Cosmos came to be so
it's kind of a memoir and it got some
nice accolades but then my uh my
wanderings in podcast World led me to
write myself second book which is called
think like a Nobel Prize winner so next
time Gary's in Montana you can pick this
book up and this is based on nine of the
14 interviews I've done with Nobel Prize
winners trying to distill not their
scientific Legacy or their scientific
contributions but more their life
lessons how do you collaborate how do
you take these lessons if you're uh you
know a member of the uh you know of the
of the staff at the um uh you know at
the at the dog pound there and you're
cleaning up maybe you still have to work
with people have to collaborate and I
should say I'm very very
um uh thrilled one of my graduate
students
um her father played for the Cleveland
Browns uh back I think in the 90s and
late 80s and her mother went to Case
Western so cool connection stay tuned
for her great success
um and she'll be on the channel at some
point too so anyway I'm gonna wrap up
there are images and and stuff you can
find on my website brianking.com
get all my books there listen to my
podcast subscribe to the newsletter
remember how to do that it's pretty easy
just click on that subscribe button
join the mailing list you might win a
meteorite and stay in touch thanks very
much I have a couple minutes before I
have to go babysit for a couple
questions
Brian thank you very very much
um
very uh amusing but also entertaining
yeah it sounds like you've developed a
good sense of humor over over uh over
the situation
um but yeah I know you gotta get going
but any questions uh any questions for
Dr Keating before he has to go to enjoy
the rest of his evening on the Left
Coast
I first of all I want to say thanks that
was a lot of fun
um and uh I wanted to ask you a question
when you were down at the South Pole gym
across uh Paz with uh Chris Martin by
any chance no I didn't because I was
down there working on the Astro
telescope I don't know yeah yeah I'm
familiar with that um professor John
rule at Case Western is a close
collaborator and he he goes to South
Paul quite frequently
the only reason I brought it up is he
and I had a project we were going to
take that telescope and actually
refurbish it and put it up on the
Atacama Plateau oh wow as a remote uh
remotely operated telescope we wrote the
proposals and everything else never did
get the funding but it would have been a
lot of fun it would have been that's too
bad yeah so I'm familiar with uh yeah
you got to wear oxygen yeah it is an
unforgiving environment yes it is
I have something
um Mrs Gene Bishop Brian
um I understand that the nebulosity
around the Pleiades stars is really of a
different uh distance and a different
um entirely uh separate nature and it
just happens to be a coincidence that
the two are aligned with our observation
at this time is isn't that so
no um to the extent in which we know the
distance of the Pleiades which is uh
actually highly uncertain there are
radio measurements done by actually a
scientists here at UC San Diego that
differ from optically derived Parallax
derived distances but the um the the
light most of the light that I showed
around maripi which is I think in the
lower left as we were reviewing it
um It's associated with the formation of
those Stars themselves so there are you
know kind of um you know from reflection
nebula you see the same spectrum of the
if you take a slit and you put it on the
nebula only you get the same spectral
characteristics as if you put it
directly on the star
so that would indicate it's very close
in proximity
Toledo
um you're using the similarity of
elements in in the two at least one star
and one part of that that nebula is it
any chance that other parts of the
nebula are at different distances
well I mean again the nebula the
Pleiades themselves is quite large I
mean it's many many times the distance
you know of our solar system to the Oort
cloud I forget the actual
um distance but it may be you know
several thousand Au in diameter so to
say that any one star is exactly located
at any you know in the exact same
nebulosity envelope
um may not be so controversial as as you
might be thinking about it but no I mean
there's it would be a heck of a
coincidence to be spatially localized
chemically identical spectroscopically
identical and not be you know and just
be a random coincidence I can't imagine
how that could occur but
um I would have to look at this
particular announcement in more detail
as I said the actual distance is
uncertain at the level of several
parsecs to tens of parsecs at the few
percent level which is quite large by
um Parallax standards
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you
anybody else
okay you're actually kidding we greatly
appreciate your time thanks for hanging
out with us this evening virtual Round
of Applause for you sir yeah um we look
forward to getting your uh digital
literature through our varied Internet
devices
um but thank you for your time this was
a really fun talk uh thank you speak
speaking committee great job uh in
reaching out and getting another great
speaker for our October meeting okay
Brian if you're ever if you're ever in
Cleveland or ever planning on coming to
Cleveland let me know maybe I can get
you in front of about 300 people at BW
oh I would love that yeah for now I put
my link to my mailing list and the in
the chat and my YouTube channel is
available there too cool thanks guys
been a pleasure thanks everybody you all
have a great night thank you very much